el presidente de donald trump hizo el
anuncio en su cuenta de twitter twitter
resalto estos anuncios por falta de
veracidad y la del despido será después
de que christopher crepes dijera que
ningún voto se perdió fue eliminado o se
comprometió en el sistema electoral la
desvía sin embargo de crepes pues ya se
venía esperando después de que varios
medios de comunicación afines al
presidente camps pues criticaran a
crepes precisamente por tomar esta
postura por decir que había sido una de
las elecciones más limpias en la
historia de eeuu
crepes por su parte respondió en su
cuenta de twitter diciendo que había
sido un honor trabajar para la agencia
de ciberseguridad y que era importante
proteger el presente para asegurar el
futuro también renunció mat greivis en
la agencia de seguridad era el director
adjunto lo hizo en apoyo a su jefe
christopher crepes y el otro tema de
cristóbal en el país es la selección de
joe biden de los futuros miembros para
su equipo que se sabe de esos perfiles
si nombró un grupo extenso de asesores
en la casa blanca entre ellos está steve
wyche tea y mike donilon que pues fueron
cercanos a él durante la campaña ahora
serán altos asesores del presidente en
la casa blanca estará también el yen o
miley que será la directora adjunta de
el jefe de gabinete también está van a
gamers que será alta consejera para la
casa blanca llama la atención pues la
presencia de llull y rodríguez
ella es la nieta de césar chávez es
chávez fue una activista en eeuu que
protegió los derechos de los inmigrantes
indocumentados en este país y es la
única latina en hacer parte de este
grupo de nuevos nombrados para ser parte
del equipo de yo vayan a la casa blanca
también están y tomen cine pero pues
estas personas todavía no van a poder
empezar el proceso de transición
precisamente porque trump tiene todavía
pues frenado este proceso y no ha
desembolsado la plata necesaria para
este